ah
this is here right now and she won't
shut the [ __ ] up hi everybody it's
breaking my heart I'm in love with her
Wow I just really wanna have sex with
her I'm kidding Alyssa that's not true
only masturbated to you like twice three
to redemption oh that's the wrong one
the raid to Barrett doll brand Oh
Brendan Fraser I don't know I don't
remember the correct way to pronounce
this this movie was awesome as [ __ ] [ __ ]
has never been this awesome aboard oh
man awesome [ __ ] but this is the
greatest fun I've ever had so much to
talk about let's get into this first
office story I love how they just
advanced the story so much first one was
like die hard oh and insane martial arts
just a really fun action flick then this
sequel it's not only ten times bigger
it's like a straight-up
crime epic you explore the underworld of
the Indonesian mob and even the Japanese
mom it would be really weird and it
wouldn't make sense if it featured the
Italian mob like Rama he's not just the
main focus of the story at one point
you're like what the [ __ ] ever Rama
that's not to say that Rama's characters
not interesting they amped up his
character by far I mean look at him he's
just badass he is Baron doll I think I
use that right I'm like the [ __ ] I am
I didn't bother to look up this guy's
name I just call him Rama and that is
all I want to know him as Rama is these
[ __ ] but a much bigger [ __ ] this time
around the hugest [ __ ] you'll ever see
toilet clogged with his head shaved
he just looks 10 times more threatening
he has an undercover mission of we're
gonna throw you into the prison to make
you look like a real convict where he
goes undercover and he has to find that
line between being a criminal and being
a cop just this character development a
descent into darkness he had to do was
so damn good but this is a wonderful
performance for an action hero man what
I loved about this film is its focus on
the villains it kind of reminds me of
The Dark Knight because the first one is
kind of like Rama's beginnings then this
one is like a crime ensemble piece you
cut or you suck or I don't know how to
say Indonesian name sorry the son of the
Indonesian mob boss this guy's a cocky
little [ __ ] his whole life is all about
trying to make daddy happy but he's not
just some like annoying spoiled little
brat there are times where he's like
whoa don't want to [ __ ] with this
pervert he's intimidating he's another
character that has a full character
development by the end of the film
there's a twist in the film with him
that I didn't
he coming just like how elicit didn't
see me coming Oh
oh [ __ ] it's a great focus of a villain
then he got you caught dad the
Indonesian crime boss forgot the
character's name apparently I'm not lazy
to do a hilarious opening bit I'm too
lazy to go on IMDB and look up this
guy's name he was fantastic in the role
what I love about his performance was
that you didn't play like mr. bad guy
the times you totally get the reasoning
behind this dude he feels like a actual
father who happens to have an evil side
inside of him like most of your father's
out there his first scene with Rama was
great he forces Rama to get naked and no
unfortunately you don't get to see
Rama's wing and England as much as you
want to the director decided not to show
it damn shame I imagine most women that
Rama has sex with accidentally died
because of how fast he can [ __ ] just
each character in this movie has so much
depth even if you don't explore them
entirely you still feel like all of them
are 3-dimensional even got bad asses to
come late into the film but coming just
at the right time like hammer girl she's
like this hot-ass Japanese chick who
murders people with hammers incredibly
badass
I would love to bone her while she holds
a hammer up against my throat they even
brought Mad Dog back well they didn't
bring the character back they brought
that B actor to play a different
character which is greatly confusing at
first but eventually you just buy this
guy like you sympathize for him you get
him the guy's a great actor he's the
same actor playing two different
characters first movie he's as
terrifying dude second movie you like
love him and you really care about him
you just want to pet him then you got
baseball bat guy dude using a baseball
bat has never looked this cool before he
made me want to go to Dodger Stadium
some of the best fight scenes are with
him okay the fight scenes everyone know
is especially if you've seen the first
one that the fight scenes are gonna be
[ __ ] epic now here's what I love this
movie even more no it's not as
simplistic fun as the first one and at
times there is so much story that I was
actually a little bit confused weird to
be confused at a movie you're reading
the whole time but there's like a solid
30 to 40 minutes where there's no action
it's just story cuz this action movie
really believes in having an emotional
impact it's a buildup movie build-up is
the great kind of movie it's also the
best kind of sexual intercourse they
have ain't that right Alyssa like each
fight scene is unique
different than the last one but it's not
nonstop action throughout the fight
scenes are spread apart they come in at
exactly the right time to add the right
emotional impact the film's intensity
literally escalates from beginning to
end like by the time you get to the
finale you have so much excitement and
so much chills before the finale fight
even begins everyone in the audience was
like a [ __ ]
shits about the oh damn [ __ ]
there's a black guy sitting nicely
dude each fight scene is just brilliant
it's super stylistic it feels like this
shake it actually happened the violence
is just amped up at a whole new level
whole oh I mean don't get me wrong the
fight scenes are still incredibly badass
I imagine every fighter in this movie
has a really toned ass I don't like the
first one where you're just like oh dang
oh [ __ ] damn you still do that [ __ ] but
the fighting just seems so much darker
seems more violent not just good as ten
times more bloody but because the
villains and the all the characters are
just so great and believable it just
feels like real violence like it's not
always fun it's scary at times that
finale holy [ __ ] one of the best finales
I have ever seen ever you've got to
watch this in your local cinema Plex the
music is superb kinda reminds me of
Drive cinematography is gorgeous just
that opening shot man oh-ho damn the
directing writing and editing by Gareth
Evans [ __ ] solid as ever the first
one had more of an off the cuff buy this
one just felt so much more solidified I
don't need to say more except this the
only complaint I heard about the first
rate was that it lacked in story I
actually disagree with that but it seems
like you're that runs herb and everyone
said and said fine I'm gonna give you
guys a [ __ ] to the story and I'm gonna
amp up everything that everyone loved
them at the first one and he did just
that it is without a doubt one of the
best action movies I have ever witnessed
so thank you all you Indonesian
subscribers for recommending this movie
to me and the few Americans that have
seen it too and some other foreigners it
was one of the best movie experiences
I've ever had let me get straight to the
point here all I gotta say the raid 2
got it super duper [ __ ] right
alright guys thanks check them out of
you for the rate tube
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me which two
chicks do you want to see fight each
other and ago I see Marissa straight to
the point and I want to mention real
fast to that I did it spoiler review
with Jeri and Sally hot ass redhead try
to have sex with her for months ain't
working the way I wanted to but I'll let
you guys know when it happens and last
but not least if you want to get updated
every time one of my reviews or videos
is out gonna clean this butter I like
dick to subscribe that's right the dick
let me say something about this little
Rama he has rated all kinds of vaginas
not in a rapey kind of way it was
consensual sex primarily hookers